den can see jens lehmann hat mal wieder
einen rausgehauen
jens lehmann ehemaliger deutscher
nationaltorhüter deutscher englischer
und italienischer meister
uefa-cup-sieger brillen die banden
finkler und seit gestern der kettensägen
man vom starnberger see dort soll er am
montagnachmittag den carport seines
nachbarn versagt haben weil dieser ihm
mit seiner garage den seeblick genommen
hat die sicht auf seinen schönen
starnberger see schön wenn man ein
grundstück hier am starnberger see hat
doof ist es allerdings nur wenn der
seeblick durch die garage des nachbarn
verdeckt wird vermutlich das hat sich
jens lehmann gedacht der
ex-nationaltorhüter als er am
montagnachmittag auf die garage eines
nachbarn geklettert ist er hatte eine
kettensäge im gepäck ist auf die garage
geklettert und hat einen dachbalken
durchgesetzt ist entstand ein schaden
von mehreren hundert euro der plan war
nahezu perfekt er hat sogar die
überwachungskamera vom nachbargrundstück
ausgestöpselt wofür lehmann sie hatte
eine batterie und habt ein live-bild der
musik zu übertragen der hat die polizei
gerufen die es an gerückt hat mit jens
lehmann gesprochen in den vergangenen
jahren gab es an derselben garage schon
andere beschädigungen insgesamt drei
stück mit einem schaden von 10.000 euro
und jetzt prüft die polizei ob wir uns
jemand auch für diese schäden in frage
kommt es ist nicht das erste mal dass
sich der torhüter des wm-sommermärchens
2006 verzettelt die rübe historie von
jens lehmann
2008 in seiner zeit beim vfb stuttgart
fliegt lehmann des öfteren mit dem
hubschrauber zum training der grund 205
sich kilometer mit dem auto fahren ist
einfach zu weit oktober 2009 lehmann
beleidigt einen balljungen weil dieser
den ball vor dem keeper weggeworfen hat
dezember 2009 lehmann erleichtert sich
hinter einer wand der beim champions
league spiele im selben monat entwendet
er einem fan die brille und bekommt eine
anzeige
2021 äußert sich lehmann rassistisch
gegenüber des ex-nationalspielers dennis
aogo denn die ihnen einen quoten
schwarzen darauf fünf liegt lehmann bei
hertha bsc als aufsichtsratmitglied aus
oder auch seinen job als tv experte ist
er danach los sowohl auf als auch neben
dem fußballfeld so kleemann für
entgleisungen das ist nichts neues sein
debüt feierte allerdings mit der
kettensäge jens lehmann der kettensägen
man vom starnberger see
[Musik]